From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I think the thing that gets to me the most about the story that we're doing today is I feel for the parents in this story.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我觉得我们今天报道的这个故事最触动我的地方在于，我非常同情故事里的父母。
Like when you're a parent, at some point you're in the situation where your kid is having experiences and friendships with people that are completely out of your reach, right? You don't know what's really happening between them. You don't really know what's going through your kid's head. You're powerless.
作为父母，在某个阶段，你的孩子会拥有一些你完全无法触及的经历和人际关系，对吧？你不知道他们之间到底发生了什么。你真的不知道孩子脑子里在想什么。你感到无能为力。
The parents in the story today, they thought they were close to their son, who was doing really well in school. Things seemed fine. Anyway, it's our whole hour today, a story we call Chip in My Brain. David Kestenbaum tells what happened, which begins with basketball.
今天故事里的父母，他们以为自己很了解儿子，儿子在学校表现也很出色。一切看起来都很正常。总之，这是我们今天整整一小时的节目，故事名为《我大脑里的芯片》。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）将讲述事情的经过，故事始于篮球。
It would probably be wrong to say that Cody Treybig loved basketball at the beginning. It would definitely be wrong to say he was good at it. He wasn't at all. He was good at World of Warcraft though, the video game.
说科迪·特雷比格（Cody Treybig）一开始就热爱篮球，可能不太准确。说他擅长篮球就更不对了。他一点也不擅长。但他很擅长玩电子游戏《魔兽世界》。
Sometimes I still almost cry thinking about the first time I walked into Stormwind, the capital human city. And the music changes. And you see this beautiful, huge castle. And you're walking in, and it's like-- it's just really-- it's amazing.
有时想到第一次走进人类主城暴风城的情景，我还是会热泪盈眶。音乐变了，你看到那座美丽而巨大的城堡。你走进去，感觉就像——这真的——太神奇了。
Cody says he wasn't exactly avoiding physical activity. The game was just super fun. He and his friends would all log on, go on adventures together. As someone who used to play a lot of video games, it felt like bad etiquette not to ask who his online character was.
科迪说他并不是在刻意回避体育锻炼。只是游戏太好玩了。他和朋友们一起登录，一起去冒险。作为一个曾经玩过很多电子游戏的人，我觉得如果不问问他的游戏角色是谁，显得很不礼貌。
Cody told me-- and knowing him a little bit now, this seems entirely appropriate-- he was a paladin, which is a holy knight who can fight. But also, he's nice. He casts healing spells when his co-adventurers get hurt. Cody eventually built them up to level 60, as high as you can go.
科迪告诉我——现在稍微了解他一点之后，觉得这完全符合他的性格——他玩的是圣骑士，一个能战斗的圣骑士。而且他人很好。当队友受伤时，他会施放治疗法术。科迪最终把他们练到了60级，那是当时的满级。
I was just really proud of having six-eighths of Lightforge gear, which was nothing. But--
我当时特别自豪，因为我凑齐了六分之八的“光铸”装备，虽然那其实算不了什么。但是——
All of which is just to say that sports were not Cody's top priority. In gym class when they'd have to run laps, he'd always be at the back. Basketball somehow though, he kind of liked. His dad had played when he was growing up. So early on, in third grade, Cody found himself on this local youth league team.
说这一切只是想表达，运动并不是科迪的首要任务。体育课上要跑圈时，他总是落在最后。不过不知为何，他还是挺喜欢篮球的。他爸爸小时候打过球。所以早在他三年级的时候，科迪就参加了当地的青年联盟球队。
I was not very athletic at all. I remember being at basketball games with my friend Daniel. And we'd be talking about World of Warcraft while the game was going on on the bench.
我那时一点也不运动。我记得和朋友丹尼尔一起参加篮球赛时，我们在替补席上打球的同时，却在讨论《魔兽世界》。
OK. Well, from Mom's perspective, I thought he was adorable.
好吧。从妈妈的角度来看，我觉得他很可爱。
That's Mom, Drew Treybig. And here's Dad, Jimmy Treybig.
那是妈妈，德鲁·特雷比格（Drew Treybig）。这是爸爸，吉米·特雷比格（Jimmy Treybig）。
He wasn't real aggressive.
他那时并不怎么好斗。
He's in the middle of the court, watching everybody run back and forth.
他站在球场中央，看着大家跑来跑去。
And if he got the ball and someone wanted it, he'd just give it to them.
如果他拿到球，有人想要，他就会直接给他们。
He would just so sweetly hand it off to another player. I didn't really have a problem with that, to be honest, at that age. He was little. I thought, this is my dear, sweet boy. And he'll get it. He'll get it eventually. But it bothered him, after a while, that the boys were making fun of him.
他会那么甜美地把球交给另一个球员。老实说，在那个年纪，我并不觉得这有什么问题。他还小。我想，这是我亲爱、甜美的孩子。他会明白的。他终究会明白的。但过了一段时间，男孩们嘲笑他，这让他感到很困扰。
Drew describes herself as a kind of helicopter mom, which seems right. While I was there talking to Cody, she kept momming us. Are you guys hungry? How about a smoothie? I'm going to get one.
德鲁形容自己是一个“直升机妈妈”，这形容很贴切。当我在那儿和科迪交谈时，她一直在照顾我们。“你们饿吗？来杯冰沙怎么样？我去买一杯。”
Drew says the whole family is kind of kooky. Whenever someone was leaving, they'd be sure to say I love you, to the other person. And I don't mean leaving the house, just like leaving the room. Cody's dad, Jimmy, says he had a hard time getting his father to say I love you. So this is their fix.
德鲁说全家人都有点古怪。每当有人要离开时，他们一定会对彼此说“我爱你”。我指的不是离开家，只是离开房间。科迪的爸爸吉米说，他很难让他自己的父亲说出“我爱你”。所以这是他们的解决办法。
The Treybigs live in Texas in the outskirts of Austin. Jimmy was an early tech entrepreneur. He founded a company that made the computers that ran ATM machines. So they had a nice house on a big piece of land. There were cows around, but no neighbors you could walk to, which Jimmy told me he regretted.
特雷比格一家住在德克萨斯州奥斯汀郊外。吉米是一位早期的科技创业者。他创办了一家制造ATM机电脑的公司。所以他们在一大片土地上拥有一个不错的房子。周围有牛，但没有可以步行拜访的邻居，吉米告诉我他对此感到遗憾。
As it happened, there was an old basketball court out behind the house. So they decided to get Cody some lessons. Like instead of a piano teacher or something, get him a basketball teacher. His dad found someone through the local youth league, a guy named AJ. Cody is in third grade at the time.
碰巧的是，房子后面有一个旧的篮球场。所以他们决定给科迪请教练。就像给孩子请钢琴老师一样，给他请个篮球老师。他爸爸通过当地青年联盟找到了一个人，一个叫AJ的家伙。当时科迪在上三年级。
So I remember the first meeting. He came in the front door. And he was just very friendly, is what I remember feeling at the time, tall, 6 foot 6".
我记得第一次见面。他从前门进来。我记得当时的感觉是他非常友好，个子很高，有6英尺6英寸。
And I think I probably asked him, oh my god, can you dunk? And he's like, oh yeah, I can dunk. He said they used to call him "Springs" was his nickname because he dunked a lot.
我想我当时可能问他：“天哪，你能扣篮吗？”他说：“哦，是的，我能扣篮。”他说以前别人叫他“弹簧”，因为他扣篮很多。
So that first day, AJ walks in. They all hang out by the front door. Cody is shy, but AJ gets right down on his level. The two of them go out to the basketball court, talking the whole way. When they get there, Cody can't really even do a layup.
那天AJ进门时，他们都在前门附近。科迪很害羞，但AJ很快和他打成一片。两人一路聊天走到篮球场。到了那儿，科迪甚至连上篮都不会。
And AJ is like, OK, we can fix this. Let's do some basics. He teaches Cody this drill where you stand just to the side of the basket, try to bank it in off this magic spot. Then you get the rebound, go to the other side, and do it again, back and forth, back and forth.
AJ说：“好吧，我们可以解决这个问题。让我们做些基础训练。”他教科迪一个练习：站在篮筐侧面，尝试利用那个“魔法点”打板进球。然后抢篮板，到另一边，再做一次，来来回回。
And he would put his hand through the hoop and act like a little monster, a dragon or something, squiggle his fingers around like, feed the monster. Feed the monster. [CHUCKLES] So I thought that was pretty fun.
他会把手伸过篮筐，像个小怪物，或者龙之类的东西，手指扭动着说：“喂食小怪兽。喂食小怪兽。”（轻笑）我觉得那挺好玩的。
AJ works with Cody two days a week, then three days a week. Sometimes other kids come over so they can all train together. And it's great. Mom would bring out snacks for everyone. Or if other kids weren't around, Mom or Dad would get drafted.
AJ每周和科迪训练两天，后来是三天。有时其他孩子也会过来，他们可以一起训练。这很棒。妈妈会给每个人拿零食。如果其他孩子不在，妈妈或爸爸会被拉来陪练。
We would stand there and pretend to be a player on the other team so that they could-- or he told us to try to move into them, or try to steal the ball, or you know. So we could kind of be silly doing that too, right?
我们会站在那儿假装是对方球队的球员，这样他们就可以——或者他告诉我们尝试朝他们移动，或者尝试抢断球，等等。所以我们做这些事时也能显得有点傻，对吧？
Was that fun?
那好玩吗？
Yeah. Yeah. It was really fun-- but not on the hot days. I'd say, AJ, I don't want to do this. It's too hot. [LAUGHS]
是的。是的，真的很有趣——但在天气热的时候就不好了。我会说：“AJ，我不想做了。太热了。”（笑）
Word spreads around town about this great basketball trainer. Other parents hire him. But AJ and Cody, they have something kind of special. They just click, and they have this way of being around each other that seems sweet.
关于这位出色的篮球教练的消息在城里传开了。其他家长也雇用了他。但AJ和科迪之间有种特殊的东西。他们一拍即合，相处的方式看起来很甜蜜。
When AJ was working with Cody, they would trash talk on the court, which I always thought of as involving a lot of swearing. But AJ taught Cody this really hilarious kind of trash talking-- just messing with someone, asking weird, random questions in the middle of the game. Hey, what did you have for breakfast?
当AJ训练科迪时，他们会在球场上说垃圾话，我一直以为那涉及很多脏话。但AJ教了科迪一种非常滑稽的垃圾话——只是戏弄别人，在比赛中问些奇怪、随机的问题。“嘿，你早餐吃了什么？”
He would act like my mom sometimes. He would talk in my mom's voice and be like, OK, Cody, make the shot. Time to make the shot. Let's go. Let's get in there and try hard. [LAUGHS] And that would obviously crack me up, and it would be hard to focus.
他有时会模仿我妈妈。他会用我妈妈的声音说：“好吧，科迪，投篮。是时候投篮了。走吧。进去努力点。”（笑）这显然会让我笑喷，很难集中注意力。
Cody played constantly. If the family went on a trip, he would deflate a basketball, stick it in the suitcase, then re-inflate it after they arrived. When you're a kid, you want there to be something that you're special at, or even just a little good at.
科迪一直都在打球。如果全家去旅行，他会把篮球放气，塞进手提箱，到达目的地后再重新充气。当你是个孩子时，你希望自己能在某方面特别，或者至少有点擅长。
Because as a kid, you start off being terrible at everything. That is the definition of being a kid. So when you meet someone who helps you get good at something, it can feel amazing. Cody remembers this one afternoon-- maybe fourth grade, on the court out back-- where it all just felt perfect.
因为作为一个孩子，你开始时什么都很糟糕。这就是孩子这一词的定义。所以当你遇到一个能帮你擅长某事的人时，那感觉太棒了。科迪记得有一个下午——大概是在四年级，在后院的球场上——感觉一切都很完美。
We were just doing jump shots. And I was making like all of them, like never done-- making all of them. And one of my brother's friends had come to hang out with my brother. And he was up at the top watching us. And I noticed that. And I was like-- to me, he was older and cool.
我们只是在练习跳投。我几乎全都投进了，从来没这样过——全都投进了。我哥哥的一个朋友过来找我哥哥玩。他在上方看着我们。我注意到了。对我来说，他年纪大而且很酷。
And I was making them. And he could see I was making them. And I had just this pride, just like it's something I loved, the shooting. And I was doing good at it. And I just remember feeling like I was, yeah, floating on air. It was really nice.
我投进了。他能看到我投进了。我感到非常自豪，因为这是我热爱的事情，投篮。我做得很好。我记得感觉自己就像，是的，飘在云端。那感觉真好。
And AJ was there?
AJ当时也在吗？
Yeah. He was coaching me. He was rebounding and giving me the passes.
是的。他在指导我。他在抢篮板并给我传球。
The next year, Cody got the MVP award for the school team. In some ways, AJ was like a big kid himself. Drew says he often seemed more comfortable with kids than adults. And as Cody gets older, he and AJ really start to become friends. After his games, Cody would always call AJ to tell him how it went.
第二年，科迪获得了学校球队的MVP奖。在某些方面，AJ自己就像个大孩子。德鲁说他似乎和孩子相处比和成年人相处更自在。随着科迪长大，他和AJ真的开始成为朋友。比赛后，科迪总会给AJ打电话告诉他表现如何。
Which kind of drove my parents nuts, actually, because they wanted to talk to me after the game in the car. And I would be talking to AJ on the phone the whole way home, [CHUCKLES] which just shows how close we were.
这实际上让我父母抓狂，因为他们想在回家的车上跟我谈谈。而我却全程都在跟AJ打电话（轻笑），这恰恰说明了我们有多亲密。
AJ would sometimes pick Cody up from middle school. Cody started to listen to the music AJ listened to. Young MC, "Bust a Move" was a favorite. When Cody went out clothes shopping with his mom, he picked out clothes that looked like things AJ would wear-- simple, solid color T-shirts. Cody fell in love with basketball. And he kind of fell in love with AJ.
AJ有时会从中学接科迪放学。科迪开始听AJ听的音乐。Young MC的《Bust a Move》是他的最爱。当科迪和妈妈去买衣服时，他选的衣服看起来就像AJ会穿的那样——简单的纯色T恤。科迪爱上了篮球。他也某种程度上爱上了AJ。
I would hug him and tell him I loved him, yeah. I mean, I would jump up, and he was holding me in the air, or whatever, yeah, and tell him I loved him, yeah. I would get sad when he left. I was shy. But once I got to know people, I got very attached to them.
我会拥抱他并告诉他我爱他，是的。我的意思是，我会跳起来，他会把我举在空中，或者什么的，是的，告诉他我爱他。他离开时我会感到难过。我很害羞。但一旦我认识了人，我就会变得非常依赖他们。
There's something Cody wrote about AJ that sums up how he felt and also weirdly foreshadows what was to come. It's from early on, a school assignment to write about your hero. I had Cody read from it.
科迪写过一段关于AJ的话，总结了他的感受，也奇怪地预示了将要发生的事情。这是很早以前学校布置的作业，写关于你的英雄。我让科迪读了一下。
"Some people in fourth grade might have picked their heroes because they're national celebrities. But I picked mine because he has made me a better person."
“四年级时，有些人选择他们的英雄是因为他们是国家级名人。但我选择他是因为他让我变成了一个更好的人。”
Cody runs through how they met the way a fourth grader would.
科迪按照四年级学生的方式讲述了他们的相遇。
"Ding dong goes our doorbell. [CHUCKLES] He was here. I closed my eyes and hoped. Then the door opened. 'Hey, Cody,' he said with happiness. 'Hi, AJ,' I replied."
“叮咚，门铃响了。（轻笑）他来了。我闭上眼睛祈祷。然后门开了。‘嘿，科迪，’他高兴地说。‘嗨，AJ，’我回答道。”
The essay ends with an interview, Cody asking AJ what seemed like innocuous questions. Where did you grow up? What was your favorite subject in school? And then these two questions.
作文结尾是一次采访，科迪问了AJ一些看似无害的问题。你在哪长大的？你在学校最喜欢的科目是什么？然后是这两个问题。
What values do you think are important? And he says, "Communication and 'Thy shalt not have any gods before me,' and, 'Do unto others as you would have them do unto you.'" Did you have a hero in your life? "Yes, Christ."
你认为什么价值观很重要？他说：“沟通和‘除了我之外，不可有别神’，以及‘己所欲，施于人’。”你生命中有英雄吗？“是的，基督。”
Is it hard to get back in the mind of yourself writing this, when you wrote this?
回到写下这些东西时的自己，很难吗？
It's very hard, because now I know kind of what was going on. And so it's pretty sad, I think.
这非常困难，因为现在我知道了当时发生了什么。所以我认为这相当令人悲伤。
Fast forward to the morning of February 7, 2012. Cody's in ninth grade. He and AJ have been hanging out for six years. Here's Drew, Cody's mom.
快进到2012年2月7日的早上。科迪上九年级了。他和AJ已经交往了六年。这是德鲁，科迪的妈妈。
At that point, I was driving Cody to school. And I don't remember why. But I dropped him off. And just as I'm getting ready to leave, my friend whips into the spot next to me. And so I put my window down. She put her window down.
当时，我正开车送科迪去学校。我不记得为什么了。但我把他放下。就在我准备离开时，我的朋友猛地转进了我旁边的车位。我放下车窗。她也放下车窗。
And she's sobbing. She's not even the tearing up kind of person. And she handed me-- she said, oh my god, oh my god. You need to see what AJ has done. I found some transcripts with my son. Here they are.
她泣不成声。她根本不是那种会流泪的人。她递给我——她说：“哦，天哪，哦，天哪。你需要看看AJ做了什么。我发现了一些我儿子和他的聊天记录。就在这儿。”
They were instant messages between the woman's son, Lucas, and AJ. AJ had been coaching Lucas too. And they'd been typing back and forth over Skype. Lucas's mom had printed them out.
那是那个女人的儿子卢卡斯（Lucas）和AJ之间的即时通讯记录。AJ也在指导卢卡斯。他们一直在Skype上打字聊天。卢卡斯的妈妈把它们打印了出来。
And I read them. And it was as if my entire body went numb. It's still really hard to talk about. [CRYING]
我读了它们。感觉全身都麻木了。现在谈论这件事仍然非常困难。（哭泣）
There didn't seem to be anything physical going on. The messages were about religion, but not any religion that Drew was familiar with-- stuff from the Bible, but also things that were definitely not in the Bible. Some of it seemed really out there and scary.
看起来并没有发生任何身体上的接触。消息是关于宗教的，但不是德鲁熟悉的任何宗教——内容来自圣经，但也包含一些绝对不在圣经里的东西。有些内容看起来非常离谱且吓人。
I knew I had to get home. And she told me-- she said, go home right away. You've got to check Cody's Skype transcripts. And I'm an Apple person. I really don't know anything about the PC, the Skyping, and the keyboard even. I mean, everything seems different. So I say to her, I don't know if I'm going to be able to do it.
我知道我必须回家。她告诉我——她说：“马上回家。你得去查查科迪的Skype记录。”我是个苹果用户。我真的对电脑、Skype和键盘一窍不通。我的意思是，一切看起来都不同。所以我对她说：“我不知道我能不能做到。”
I couldn't get home fast enough, because I knew in my heart it was going to be terrible. I got home. Nobody was here. And I went to Cody's room, and his Skype log was up. So he must have been on it that morning right before school.
我迫不及待地想回家，因为我的内心知道那将是可怕的。我回到家。没人在这儿。我去了科迪的房间，他的Skype记录是打开的。所以他那天早上上学前一定用了它。
She sits there at Cody's desk and starts to read. Cody and AJ had been messaging and Skyping, sometimes late into the night, and clearly trying to hide it from her. The first pages are from some night when she'd been threatening to take his phone away.
她坐在科迪的书桌前开始阅读。科迪和AJ一直在互发信息和Skype，有时到深夜，显然是在瞒着她。前几页来自某天晚上，她威胁要没收他的手机时。
Cody writes to AJ, "How do I communicate with you without technology"" AJ, "Please turn off everything and remain calm as possible. This is just for tonight." Cody, "Should I give them my phone if they ask for it?" AJ, "Delete everything and give it to them." She keeps reading, and it gets even stranger.
科迪写给AJ：“我如何在没有技术的情况下与你沟通？”AJ：“请关闭所有东西，尽量保持冷静。这只是今晚而已。”科迪：“如果他们问我要，我该把手机给他们吗？”AJ：“删掉所有东西然后给他们。”她继续读着，情况变得更加奇怪了。
Rapture, Illuminati, there were references to all these things, biblical or religious, that I was just astounded by.
被提（Rapture）、光照派（Illuminati），所有这些圣经或宗教的东西，让我感到极其震惊。
It was like Cody and AJ were living in this other world. And it was vast-- some mix of science fiction and stuff inspired by the Bible, particularly the book of Revelation. At the time, Drew couldn't piece it all together. But as best as I can tell, this is the basic outline of it.
就像科迪和AJ生活在另一个世界里。那是一个巨大的世界——融合了科幻小说和受圣经启发的素材，特别是《启示录》。当时，德鲁无法把这一切串联起来。但我尽我所能拼凑出了大致的轮廓。
It starts with standard evangelical beliefs about the rapture, the end of days, when a select group of people will suddenly disappear from the Earth to go live with God. And everyone else is going to be left to suffer. Who will be saved, and who will be left behind?
它始于关于“被提”的标准福音派信仰，即末日降临时，一小部分人会突然从地球上消失去与上帝同住。其他人则会被留下受苦。谁会被拯救，谁会被抛下？
Well, the devil is trying to capture as many souls as he can. And here's where the sci-fi stuff comes in. The devil is operating through a powerful and secret society called the Illuminati. The Illuminati have built a self-programming supercomputer somewhere in Belgium called "The Beast."
好吧，魔鬼正试图捕捉尽可能多的灵魂。这就是科幻元素进入的地方。魔鬼通过一个名为“光照派”的强大而秘密的社会进行运作。光照派在比利时的某个地方建造了一台名为“兽”的自编程超级计算机。
At some point, the Illuminati is going to try to control people by implanting a computer ID chip, an RFID chip, in everyone's hands or foreheads. This chip, it said, is what the Bible has been prophesying, the mark of the beast, a high-tech version of 666. If you get an RFID chip implanted, well, you are definitely not getting saved.
在某个时候，光照派将试图通过在每个人的手或前额植入电脑ID芯片，即RFID芯片，来控制人们。这个芯片，上面说，就是圣经所预言的——兽的印记，666的高科技版本。如果你植入RFID芯片，那么，你绝对无法获得拯救。
In the transcripts, AJ and Cody go back and forth about RFID chips a bunch. At one point, AJ writes, "It's here. This coming up year, it will be mandatory for all armed forces, followed by medical field, then everyone else. What it does to the body is inhuman."
在聊天记录中，AJ和科迪多次讨论RFID芯片。在某一处，AJ写道：“它来了。明年，所有武装部队都必须植入，接着是医疗领域，然后是其他人。它对身体的作用是不人道的。”
Cody, "What do they do to your body?" AJ, "You lose mind control. Why do you think I took time to study the mind with you?" Cody, "How does it do that?" AJ, "Oh, [BLEEP], here we go. Are you sure? You want to know the truth?" Cody, "Yes, I do." Then the Skype log indicates AJ called him to talk.
科迪：“他们对你的身体做了什么？”AJ：“你失去了思想控制。你以为我为什么花时间和你一起研究大脑？”科迪：“它是怎么做到的？”AJ：“哦，该死，开始了。你确定吗？你想知道真相吗？”科迪：“是的，我想知道。”然后Skype记录显示AJ打电话给他详谈。
You could see how he was manipulating by reading it. "Yes, there's more. But I guess if you're not ready to hear it--" I mean, you could see him, how he would reel a child in.
阅读这些内容，你可以看到他是如何操控的。“是的，还有更多。但我猜如果你还没准备好听到的话——”我的意思是，你可以看到他是如何将一个孩子引诱进来的。
AJ writes, "For now, rest. I have so much more to show you. But you have class tomorrow." In some places, the conversation seems very middle school, except they're texting about the apocalypse. And one of them is 36 years old.
AJ写道：“现在，休息吧。我还有更多要给你看。但你明天有课。”在某些地方，对话看起来很像初中生的聊天，只是他们在讨论末日。而其中一个人已经36岁了。
Like this time AJ is talking about how he's preparing to assist other followers of the Lord. And Cody compares the whole thing to a movie. Cody, "So it's like you're that guy from The Matrix who rescues Neo and takes him to the refuge underground."
比如有次AJ在谈论他如何准备协助主的其他追随者。科迪把整件事比作一部电影。科迪：“所以就像《黑客帝国》里那个救了尼奥并带他去地下避难所的家伙？”
AJ, "You must be talking about Morpheus." Cody, "Yes, that guy." AJ, "How do you know I'm not Neo?" Cody, "But Neo never goes and rescues people from the Matrix." AJ, "But he does show them the truth."
AJ：“你一定是在说墨菲斯。”科迪：“是的，那个人。”AJ：“你怎么知道我不是尼奥？”科迪：“但尼奥从来没有去救过人离开矩阵。”AJ：“但他确实向他们展示了真相。”
The most alarming part for Drew reading this is that AJ seems to be trying to slowly separate Cody from his family, to drive a wedge between her and her son. At one point, AJ is telling Cody that his parents are influenced by, quote, "the other side."
对德鲁来说，阅读这些内容最令人不安的部分是，AJ似乎试图慢慢地将科迪与他的家人隔离开来，在他和她儿子之间制造隔阂。在某一处，AJ告诉科迪，他的父母受到了来自“另一方”的影响。
One of the first things I had read that popped up was him telling Cody to call CPS.
我读到的第一件事就是他告诉科迪去打举报电话。
Child Protective Services?
儿童保护服务局？
Yeah, Child Protective-- and to fake that we were abusing him.
是的，儿童保护服务——并假装我们虐待他。
Cody had been asking AJ what he should do if his parents tried to make him get an RFID chip implanted. AJ writes, "CPS, one phone call, 911. You can easily claim abuse, which is not a lie because they would be forcing you into hell. Tell CPS nothing about the chip. Stress potential harm to your body and yelling." Drew reads this and worries that Cody is about to run off with AJ.
科迪一直问AJ，如果他父母试图强迫他植入RFID芯片，他该怎么办。AJ写道：“儿童保护服务局，一个电话，911。你可以轻松谎称受到虐待，这不算是撒谎，因为他们是在强迫你进入地狱。什么都不要告诉儿童保护服务局关于芯片的事。强调对你身体的潜在伤害和大吼大叫。”德鲁读到这些，担心科迪快要跟AJ逃跑了。
You can just see in this sweet, little, innocent Cody saying things like, well, I think I have some money in a savings account. And then, because AJ is telling him we're going-- he and Cody are going to need a lot of money.
你可以看到这个甜美、天真、小小的科迪说出类似“嗯，我想我的储蓄账户里有些钱”这样的话。然后，因为AJ告诉他他们要去哪儿——他和科迪将需要很多钱。
Drew calls Jimmy, her husband, who rushes home.
德鲁打电话给她的丈夫吉米，他赶回了家。
I was really afraid. And it was obviously-- it had been going on a very long time.
我真的非常害怕。显然——这已经持续了很长一段时间。
The Skype transcripts only went back a month. But they eventually learned from Cody that he and AJ had been having conversations like this for years-- right there in the house, right under their noses. Drew and Jimmy call the police, but it's unclear if there's anything they can charge AJ with.
Skype聊天记录只回溯了一个月。但他们最终从科迪那里得知，他和AJ多年来一直在进行这样的对话——就在家里，就在他们的眼皮底下。德鲁和吉米报了警，但不清楚有什么罪名可以指控AJ。
They decide for sure they need to cut off all contact with AJ, which they worry will upset Cody. They don't know how much of all this religious stuff he really believes. But they know he loves AJ. They need time to figure things out. So they just leave Cody at school for the rest of the day. He's going to classes, doesn't know any of this is happening.
他们确定需要切断与AJ的所有联系，他们担心这会令科迪不安。他们不知道科迪到底有多相信这些宗教内容。但他们知道他爱AJ。他们需要时间去弄清楚事情。所以他们那天剩下的时间只是让科迪待在学校。他在上课，根本不知道发生了这一切。
They call a friend who's a lawyer, and they make a plan. When the school day is over, Drew will pick up Cody and also his friend Lucas, who had been messaging with AJ. She'll pretend like everything's normal. But she'll take them directly to the lawyer's office, where Jimmy and the other kid's parents will be.
他们打给一位律师朋友，制定了一个计划。放学后，德鲁会去接科迪以及他的朋友卢卡斯，那个一直在跟AJ聊天的人。她会假装一切正常。但她会直接带他们去律师事务所，吉米和其他孩子的家长会等在那里。
Last period of the day, last class, I had off period, no class. And I was texting AJ about something I had seen on the internet. And I think he replied. And it was a normal day.
那天最后一节课，我没课。我正在给AJ发短信关于我在互联网上看到的东西。我想他回复了。那是正常的一天。
And my mom-- my friend Lucas and I were hanging out before my mom came and picked me up. And I think we had a basketball session that day with AJ planned. And my mom said, oh, I'm going to drive both of you guys to our house to play.
我的妈妈——我和卢卡斯在妈妈来接我之前在一起。我想我们那天计划和AJ有一个篮球训练。我妈妈说：“哦，我要开车送你们俩去我家玩。”
They were so happy that day when they got in the car. And all I'm thinking is, oh my god, it's just in a couple of minutes when I have to turn left. It's all I kept thinking about. It's just going to all come crashing down. And I don't know if I'm strong enough to do this, because I'm still barely keeping it together.
他们上车时很高兴。而我心里想的只是，哦，天哪，再过几分钟我就要左转了。这是我脑子里唯一一直在想的事。一切都要崩溃了。我不知道我是否有足够的力量去做这件事，因为我还在勉强支撑着。
So that was fine. It was normal. And we were going home. And instead of turning right, we turn left. And Lucas and I were, what's going on? Why are we turning left? And my mom wouldn't answer us. And we could tell something was weird.
所以那天很好。一切正常。我们在回家路上。本来应该右转的，结果我们向左转了。卢卡斯和我问：“怎么了？为什么我们要左转？”我妈妈没回答我们。我们可以感觉到有什么不对劲。
So immediately, Lucas and I are like, what is going on? My mind immediately turned to, oh my god, maybe my parents are taking me somewhere to implant the RFID chip in me. So I'm starting to think about how are we going to get out of this car.
所以卢卡斯和我立刻就在想，发生什么事了？我的脑子立刻转向，天哪，也许我父母正带我去植入RFID芯片的地方。所以我开始想我们要如何逃离这辆车。
The other little boy almost jumped out of the car. And I had to beg him to just please not jump out of the car. They had done nothing wrong. They weren't in trouble. They were going to be OK. But I couldn't tell them. For 20 minutes, that's all I kept saying.
另一个小男孩差点跳出车外。我不得不求他不要跳车。他们什么都没做错。他们没惹麻烦。他们会没事的。但我不能告诉他们。在那20分钟里，我一直在说那句话。
We were texting AJ like, what's going on? Do you know what's going on? We were kind of frantic. She took us to, I guess, our family lawyer at the time's office and sat us down. And they informed us that they had found Lucas's Skype transcripts with AJ.
我们当时在给AJ发短信说：“怎么了？你知道怎么回事吗？”我们有点慌乱。她把我们带到了我猜是当时我们家律师的办公室，让我们坐下。他们通知我们，他们发现了卢卡斯和AJ的Skype聊天记录。
And that prompted my parents to look at my computer. And they found my Skype transcripts with AJ and that they were going to fire him. I wouldn't be allowed to see him anymore and that he wasn't allowed to talk to us anymore.
这促使我父母查看了我的电脑。他们发现了我和AJ的Skype记录，他们要解雇他。我不被允许再见他，也不被允许再跟他说话。
So I mean it-- my world blew up. My world blew up. It was-- I don't know how else to put it. My world just blew up.
所以我的世界崩溃了。我的世界崩溃了。这——我不知道该怎么形容。我的世界就是崩溃了。
Looking at Cody, though, Drew couldn't tell what was going on with him. He didn't cry. He didn't yell. When they got home, she says she tried to talk to him about all this, but he wouldn't talk. They got him a therapist right away.
然而，看着科迪，德鲁无法判断他发生了什么。他没哭。他没喊。当他们到家时，她说她试着跟他谈谈这一切，但他不肯说话。他们立刻给他找了心理医生。
The lawyer told AJ he was fired and to stay away from the Treybigs. The family sent the school a photo of AJ, told them to watch out for him. AJ sent an email to the Treybigs' lawyer, threatening to sue them if they said bad things about him.
律师告诉AJ他被解雇了，并且离特雷比格一家远点。这家人发给学校一张AJ的照片，提醒他们提防他。AJ给特雷比格一家的律师发了一封电子邮件，威胁说如果他们说他坏话，就要起诉他们。
Cody had been a high honors student. But the next day, he got a 24 on a test. After school, he'd go to his room, stay in there, and go to sleep.
科迪曾经是优等生。但第二天，他在考试中只得了24分。放学后，他会回到房间，待在里面，然后睡觉。
In the mornings, his parents would break down. They'd say, please just come home to us today. Don't run away with him. Of course, one of the weird things about this whole situation is that before this, Cody had seemed totally normal around the house, just his regular self.
早上，他的父母会崩溃。他们会说：“求求你，今天回到我们身边吧。不要和他一起逃跑。”当然，整件事奇怪的地方在于，在此之前，科迪在家里看起来完全正常，就是平常的样子。
When I first heard this story, I honestly didn't know what to think. It seemed incredible that all this could be going on and that no one would notice. How did this happen? And why did AJ do it? The Treybigs thought he was grooming Cody for years in some evil plan to control him and pull him away from the family. But maybe AJ was just a devoted religious guy with unconventional beliefs.
当我第一次听到这个故事时，老实说我不知道该想什么。难以置信这一切竟在发生，而没人注意到。这是怎么发生的？AJ为什么要这么做？特雷比格一家认为他多年来一直在培养科迪，怀揣着某种邪恶计划来控制他，把他从家里拉走。但也许AJ只是一个有着非传统信仰的忠诚宗教人士。
We reached out to AJ, who declined multiple interview requests. Then just before we went to air, he did finally agree to talk. So we have some tape of him, which you'll hear later. He has a different version of most of this.
我们联系了AJ，他拒绝了多次采访请求。就在我们播出前，他终于同意谈谈了。所以我们录了一些他说话的录音，你稍后会听到。他对这一切的大部分内容都有不同的版本。
But here is the story from Cody and his family's perspective. Those years where life in the Treybig household felt totally ordinary, here's what Cody says was actually going on. Cody says the first time he and AJ talked about religion was back in the sixth grade. AJ had been coaching him for a few years. And this one day, AJ starts talking about that video game that Cody loved, World of Warcraft.
但这是从科迪及其家人的角度讲述的故事。在特雷比格家中生活感觉完全正常的那些年里，科迪说实际情况是这样的。科迪说他和AJ第一次谈论宗教是在六年级。AJ已经教了他几年。有一天，AJ开始谈论科迪喜爱的那个电子游戏《魔兽世界》。
We were in my garage. And that's where we had some workout equipment at the time. And he just turned so serious suddenly. He's telling me, Cody, the things in your World of Warcraft game-- these demons, these warlocks--
我们在车库里。那时我们在那儿有一些健身器材。他突然变得非常严肃。他告诉我说：“科迪，你在《魔兽世界》游戏里的那些东西——这些恶魔，这些术士——”
--all these things, they're real. And they're all around us all the time. And it's not good that you play that game, because when you play that game, these things, they can come into you.
“——所有这些，它们是真实的。而且它们一直围绕在我们身边。你玩那个游戏不好，因为当你玩那个游戏时，这些东西可以进入你的体内。”
And those things come from hell. It's a spiritual war going on around us all the time. You just can't see it. Only some people can see it. I can see it. I just remember I-- it was truly terrifying.
“那些东西来自地狱。这是一场一直发生在我们周围的精神战争。你只是看不见。只有一些人能看见。我能看见。”我记得我——那真是太恐怖了。
How did he seem?
他看起来怎么样？
He seemed compassionate, like he was looking out for me, telling me this information that I needed to hear. And he's saying, that's why you need to stop playing that game. That's why you need to start reading the Bible.
他看起来很富有同情心，就像在照顾我，告诉我我需要听到的这些信息。他说：“这就是为什么你必须停止玩那个游戏。这就是为什么你必须开始读圣经。这就是为什么你必须去教堂。这就是为什么你必须开始祈祷。这就是为什么你必须开始理解这些事，思考这些事，变得成熟。”所以对我来说，感觉就像他在保护我免受这些可怕事物的伤害。
That's why you need to go to church. That's why you need to start praying. That's why you need to start understanding these things, and thinking about these things, and maturing. So to me, it was like he was protecting me from these terrible things.
至于这一切如何保持秘密，第一次对话并非如此。那天其他孩子过来打篮球时，科迪消失在房子里。他开始哭。他告诉了他的妈妈。
As for how this could all stay secret, this first conversation didn't. When other kids came over to play basketball that day, Cody disappeared into the house. He started to cry. And he told his mom.
科迪告诉我：“天上有台电脑要杀我。”我说：“什么？你在说什么？”
Cody tells me, there's a computer in the sky that's going to kill me. I'm like, what? What are you talking about?
德鲁说，人们现在问她为什么那天没解雇AJ。她说她尝试对宗教保持开放态度。人们信仰各种各样的事情。AJ看起来是个好人。所以当科迪告诉他妈妈“我们必须取消《魔兽世界》”时，她想：“不，我们不用。”
Drew says people have asked her now why she didn't fire AJ on that day. She says she tries to be open-minded about religion. People believe all kinds of things. AJ seemed like a good guy. So when Cody tells his mom, we've got to cancel World of Warcraft, she's like, no, we don't.
科迪告诉我，我从未告诉他那个游戏是邪恶的。为什么我会允许他玩一个邪恶的游戏？嗯，我记得当时几乎对此笑出了声。
Cody's telling me that I never told him that the game was evil. And why was I allowing him to play an evil game? Well, I remember almost laughing about that.
我说：“科迪，你喜欢这个游戏。这太傻了。它不邪恶。它只是个游戏。我要去找AJ谈谈，因为这太荒谬了。”
I'm like, Cody, you love this game. This is so silly. It's not evil. It's just a game. And I'm going to go talk to AJ because this is ridiculous.
德鲁说她去找AJ谈话，他当时正在指导其他男孩。她说：“你跟科迪说了什么？他很难过。”
Drew says she went out to talk to AJ, who was coaching the other boys. She said, what did you tell Cody? He's really upset.
“哦，我很抱歉。我不是故意要让他难过的。他误解我了。我再也不会那样做了。我很抱歉。”
Oh, I'm so sorry. I didn't mean to upset him. He misunderstood me. I won't ever do it again. I'm so sorry.
我向他解释——我说：“好吧，如果你再那样做，我们就会有问题。你是被雇来当篮球教练的。所以你觉得你能不谈论那些事吗？”他向我保证他能做到。
And I explained to him-- I said, well, we're going to have a problem if you do that again. You're hired to be a basketball coach. So do you think that you can not talk about those things? And he assured me that he could.
几乎立刻，他们又谈论起了宗教。如果倒回录音，这是一个事情本可以有不同发展的时刻。科迪本可以相信他妈妈的话，认为这一切都很荒谬。但相反，他疑惑为什么他妈妈不想让他了解这些东西。
Pretty much immediately, they did talk about religion again. And this was a moment, if you rewind the tape, when things might have all gone differently. Cody could have believed his mom that all this stuff was ridiculous. But instead, he wondered why his mom didn't want him to learn about this stuff.
他崇拜AJ。而AJ所说的话，如果属实，看起来真的很重要。很难想到还有什么比这更紧急的事情。科迪取消了他的《魔兽世界》账号，并停止了玩游戏。他说，在那天之后，他们的篮球训练开始改变了。
He adored AJ. And the stuff AJ was saying, if it was true, it seemed really important. Like it's hard to think of anything that could be more urgent. Cody canceled his World of Warcraft account and stopped playing. And he says, after that day, their basketball sessions started changing.
AJ告诉科迪他并不是真的来教他打篮球的。那根本不重要。他说他被派到那里是因为他AJ是“被选中的人”。而科迪很特别。
AJ told Cody he wasn't really there to teach him basketball. That didn't really matter. He said he was sent there because he, AJ, was one of the chosen. And Cody was special.
他要么开始就说上帝指示他，现在是分享这个新事物的时候了。或者他只是叹着气，以“（沉重地叹气），他们有眼却不能看，有耳却不能听。你知道，如果他们知道就好了，如果他们知道就好了。”开始这一切。
He would either just start and say that God had instructed him that it was time that he shares this new thing with me. Or he would just start the whole thing off by just sighing and going, [SIGHS HEAVILY], they have eyes, but they can't see. They have ears, but they can't hear. You know, if only they knew, if only they knew.
我会说：“什么？”他会把获取那个信息变成一种挑战。他会说：“你还没准备好。你还没准备好。”
And I would be like, what? And he would make it such a challenge for me to get that information out of him. He would be like, you're not ready. You're not ready.
就像一个分章节揭示的故事，讲述着他们周围那个对大多数人不可见的世界。如果你知道我是谁就好了，AJ会说。AJ说他能看到恶魔在房子周围聚集。但他过来时，它们会逃走，因为它们怕他。AJ说有时他们在打球时，他能在篮球场周围看到恶魔。
It was like a story being revealed in many chapters about this whole world around them that was invisible to most people. If you only knew who I am, AJ would say. AJ said he could see demons gathering around the house. But when he came over, they'd flee because they were afraid of him. AJ said he sometimes saw demons around the basketball court while they were playing.
有时他在训练中途会停下来，看着远处的田野，然后微笑，然后继续训练，就像——
And then sometimes he would pause in the middle of the session, just look into the field in the distance, and then smile, and then keep going in the session, and like--
就好像他看见了什么？
As if he'd seen something?
——就好像他看见了什么。他会说，比如当他和我妈妈说话时，他能看到魔鬼在她背后微笑。他还告诉我关于他其他客户的事。这个客户，他爸爸是光照派的。恶魔们成群结队地在他家。
--as if he'd seen something. He would say like when he was talking to my mom, he could see the devil behind her smiling. And he would tell me this about other clients he had too. This other client, his dad's part of the Illuminati. And the demons are flocked at his house.
当他去那里时，恶魔会尖叫着逃走。他们讨厌他去那里。他告诉我，一旦那个家庭解雇了他，他看到那个他曾指导的孩子在一天之内苍老了10岁，开始变得生病和沮丧，因为魔鬼终于能够成群结队地攻击那个孩子，因为他不在身边保护他了。
And when he went there, the demons would scream and run. And they hated it when they went there. And he told me, as soon as that family fired him, he saw the kid that he was working with age 10 years in one day and start getting sick and depressed all the time, because the demons were finally able to flock to that kid and attack him, because he wasn't there to protect him anymore.
科迪爸爸的办公室感觉特别糟糕，AJ说。里面有一尊蛇的雕像。他说那是光照派的标志。碰巧，那就是我和科迪做这次采访的地方。
Cody's dad's office had a particularly bad feel about it, AJ said. There was a statue of a snake in it. He said that was a sign of the Illuminati. As it happened, that's where Cody and I were doing this interview.
桌子上确实有那条蛇。这只是他爸爸公司销售团队做的那种企业“我们做到了”的东西。但在科迪的脑海里，他周围的一切都开始有了双重的、更深层的含义。
The snake was there on the table. It's just one of those corporate "we did it" kind of things from the sales team at his dad's company. But in Cody's mind, everything around him started to have a double, deeper meaning to it.
在加利福尼亚有个波西米亚树林，光照派在那里崇拜一尊40英尺高的猫头鹰雕像。科迪问：“你觉得你爸爸为什么去加利福尼亚旅行两周？你觉得他去哪儿了？你真觉得他那儿有两周的生意吗？谁有两周的生意？那不正常。”
There's a Bohemian Grove in California where the Illuminati worship a 40-foot statue of an owl. And Cody, why do you think your dad takes two-week trips to California? Where do you think he's going? Do you really think he has business for two weeks there? Who has business for two weeks? That's not normal.
加利福尼亚真的有40英尺高的猫头鹰雕像吗？
Is there really a 40-foot statue of an owl in California?
（笑）我不知道。我真的——我不知道。
[LAUGHS] I don't know. I really-- I don't know.
确实有个巨大的猫头鹰。波西米亚树林是富人和权势人物的飞地。总统们去过那里。但科迪的爸爸说他从来没去过。AJ说的话很难反驳，尤其是如果你还在读六年级的话。
There is a giant owl. Bohemian Grove is this enclave for the rich and powerful. Presidents have been there. But Cody's dad says he's never been. The things AJ said were hard to disprove, especially if you're in sixth grade.
AJ说他能看到人们在他不在场时谈论他，他能看到人们的梦，有时能读懂他们的想法。他说，房子周围的那些恶魔正在蔓延。那个尤其令人担忧。
AJ said he could see people talking about him when he wasn't there, that he could see people's dreams, sometimes read their thoughts. And those demons around the house, he said, they're spreading. That one was particularly alarming.
当你打篮球时，你会想象周围有你看不见的小恶魔吗？
When you were playing basketball, did you imagine like little demons all around that you couldn't see?
是的。那对我来说太可怕了，因为到七八年级，他开始跟我谈论被提，以及被提随时可能发生。对我来说，在我的脑海里，他说，一旦你在精神上稳固了，一旦你的灵魂善良了，你就会看到我看到的东西。
Yes. It was horrible for me, because by seventh and eighth grade, he started talking to me about the rapture and how the rapture could happen at any second. And to me, in my mind, he said, once you're spiritually sound, once your soul is good, you'll see the things I see.
所以我一直在等我能看到恶魔的那一天。所以我有时会去球场，只是看着，然后问，“为什么我看不见？为什么我看不见？求你了，上帝，让我看看。是我做得不够多吗？”
So I was waiting for the day when I could see the demons. And so I would go to the court sometimes and just look and just, why can't I see it? Why can't I see it? Please, God, show me. Am I not doing enough?
整件事有一种紧迫感。AJ说有迹象表明被提可能发生在即将到来的奥运会期间，这意味着光照派将试图给每个人植入RFID芯片。时间所剩无几了。
There was an urgency to the whole thing. AJ said there were signs the rapture might happen during the upcoming Olympics, which meant the Illuminati were going to be trying to implant everyone with RFID chips. There was very little time left.
你脑子里怎么能装着这些事，然后早上起来，和家人一起吃早餐，开他们开的那些玩笑，然后去上学，然后——
How do you have that going on in your head, and then you get up in the morning, eat breakfast with the family, chat about whatever they're joking about, and then go to school, and--
每一秒都不正常。我会在学校走来走去。我会想，所有这些白痴，他们看不见真正发生了什么。世界末日快到了。我会花自习时间在学校走来走去，寻找AJ告诉我在圣斯蒂芬学校周围的光照派标志。我会花自习时间研究他给我看的文章，关于我爸爸的业余无线电台如何证明他是光照派的一员，以及他如何使用天线监听人们的对话。
Every second was not normal. It was-- I would walk around school. And I would think, all these idiots, they don't see what's really going on. The world's ending so soon. I would spend my off periods walking around the school looking for the Illuminati symbols AJ told me are around St. Stephen's. I would spend my offs researching articles he showed me about how my dad's ham radio is proof that he's part of the Illuminati and that he's listening in on people's conversations using his antennas.
有没有哪一部分你会质疑，觉得那听起来不像是真的？
Was there any part of you that questioned it, that was like, that doesn't sound like that's possible?
我想对我来说，当时那太可怕了，以至于我没法允许自己去质疑。我没法解释——那种感觉对我来说有多真实。就像我身处一场到处都在发生的真实战斗中。我知道一些别人不知道的东西。我是特别的。上帝选择了我。
I think for me, at the time, it was so scary that I wouldn't allow myself to question. I can't explain like how-- the way it was real to me. It was like I'm in this real battle that's happening everywhere. I know something that nobody else knows. I'm special. And God had chosen me.
是的，就像你被放进了一个幻想世界。这就像——很难解释它如何塑造你，但又同时击垮你。我的意思是，但这也是你的一部分——它只是塑造了你，就像你就是那个人。而且他以一种非常真实的方式做到了——那对我来说实在太真实了。
Yeah, it's like you're put in this fantasy world. It's like-- it's hard to explain the way it built you up but simultaneously broke you down. I mean, but it was also this part of you-- it just builds you up, like you are this person. And he did it in such a way-- it just was so real to me.
这很有趣。我觉得这发生在你作为孩子形成世界观的时候。你知道我的意思吗？就像有人把这个非常混乱的版本塞进了你脑子里。
It's funny. I feel like it's at a time where you're forming your worldview as a kid. You know what I mean? And like someone snuck this really messed up version of it into you.
是的。
Yeah.
我跟当时在场的其他孩子谈过。他们说AJ也跟他们谈过这些事。其中一个告诉我他觉得自己是个怀疑论者，但他仍然发现自己会怀疑。也许AJ知道些什么。
I talked to some other kids who were around at the time. They said AJ talked to them about this stuff too. One of them told me he sees himself as a skeptical person, but he still found himself wondering. Maybe AJ knows something.
AJ会在学校期间打手机给他们，说类似“你在安全位置吗？”之类的话。这很可怕，但也挺让人兴奋，就像你是特工一样。但科迪是AJ花时间最多的人，他相信了一切。
AJ would call him on his cell phone during school and say something like, are you in a secure location? It was scary, but also kind of exciting, like you were a secret agent. But Cody was the one AJ spent the most time with, and he believed it all.
他的朋友告诉我他们根本不知道。在他脑子里，就像科迪生活在电影里。事实证明，它确实是一部1972年的电影，名叫《被提》。
His friends told me they had no idea. In his head, it was like Cody was living inside a movie. And as it turns out, it is an actual movie from 1972 called The Rapture.
整个关于比利时有一台名为“兽”的超级计算机，连接到人们被标记数字的故事——就是出自那里。我没能得到那部电影的副本。但我们找到了一张LP唱片，里面有一个《世界大战》风格的广播剧版本。
That's where this whole story about a supercomputer called "The Beast," in Belgium, connected to people being marked with numbers-- that's where it comes from. I wasn't able to get a copy of the film. But we were able to find an LP which has a radio drama version of it in the style of War of the Worlds.
那台电脑将为世界的每个公民分配一个数字，用于所有购买和出售。我们正在设置，让每个人都被纹上一个隐形标记。我已经把我的数字纹在手上和前额上了。
The computer will assign each citizen of the world a number for use for all buying and all selling. We're setting it up so that every person will be tattooed with an invisible mark. I've already had my number tattooed on my hand and forehead.
那太神奇了。
That's amazing.
我追踪到了编剧，一位名叫乔·穆瑟（Joe Musser）的基督徒作家。他说电影的一些宣传材料是虚构的新闻报道形式，有些人以为是真的。它们在教堂里流传，甚至在一本基督教杂志上发表过。
I tracked down the screenwriter, a Christian author named Joe Musser. He said some of the promotional material for the movie was in the form of fictional news stories, which some people thought were real. They got passed around in churches and even published in one Christian magazine.
他写信说：“嘿，你们搞砸了。这不是真的。”但已经太晚了。40多年后，比利时有一台名为“兽”的超级计算机的想法，仍然存在。
He wrote in to say, hey, you messed up. This isn't true. But it was too late. 40-something years later, the idea of a supercomputer in Belgium called "The Beast," it's still around.
科迪说他早上醒来会看CNN，看看被提是否发生了，因为毫无疑问，它会出现在新闻里。AJ说的事情很可怕，但唯一安全的地方是AJ身边。所以他没有逃跑，而是回到他身边。
Cody says he would wake up in the morning and check CNN to see if the rapture had happened, because for sure, it would be on the news. The things AJ said were terrifying, but the only safe place was with AJ. So instead of running away, he'd go back to him.
我自己的思想也不安全。我有一种抽动，因为我太害怕在脑子里说“我恨上帝”，以至于我必须一直在脑子里说话。我必须说出“我非常爱上帝。上帝太神奇了。我太爱他了”这样的短语。就像我——我爱上帝。我爱上帝。
My own thoughts weren't safe. I had this tic where I was so afraid that I would say "I hate God" in my head that if I-- I had to talk constantly in my head. I had to say the phrase, I love God so much. God is so amazing. I love him so much. Like I'm-- I love God. I love God.
那将是我每一天醒着的每一个小时。我必须在脑子里不断地说出这句话，否则我担心我会把“我恨上帝”这句话说出来。然后我就会——我就会永远下地狱。我连我自己都不安全。
And that would be every waking hour of my day. I would have to say that constantly throughout in my head, or else I was afraid I would let the phrase "I hate God" out. And then I would be-- I would go to hell forever. I wasn't even safe with my own self.
科迪把这一切瞒着父母三年。就像在篮球中，你有暗号让队友知道你在跑什么战术一样，他和AJ也有一个。
Cody hid all this from his parents for three years. And just like in basketball, how you had codes so your teammates knew what play you were running, he and AJ had one too.
他甚至可能在我父母面前说什么：“嘿，我前几天和我的朋友约翰说话。他告诉我在一场比赛里他得了12分，抢了4个篮板。”我知道那意味着“去读圣经，约翰福音第12章，第4节”。
He might say, even in front of my parents or something, hey, I was talking to my friend John the other day. And he told me he had 12 points and 4 rebounds in a game. And I knew that meant go read in the Bible, John, chapter 12, or whatever, verse 4.
科迪的妈妈说她确实注意到科迪对宗教更感兴趣了。他会缠着她让他跟AJ谈论宗教。她说不。在某个时候，科迪要求接受洗礼。他妈妈担心那可能意味着AJ还在跟科迪谈论宗教，而他承诺过不再谈的。
Cody's mom says she did notice Cody was more interested in religion. He would pester her to let him talk to AJ about religion. She said no. At some point, Cody asked to get baptized. His mom worried that might mean that AJ was still talking to Cody about religion, which he'd promised not to do.
但科迪坚持说：“不，不，这只是我想做的事。”所以他们答应了。德鲁说，回想起来，这一切看起来当然非常不同。
But Cody insisted, no, no, this is just something I want to do. So they said OK. Drew says, in retrospect, of course, all this looks very different.
我觉得，作为一个妈妈，我怎么会不知道呢？这个小男孩以为他每天、每一分钟都要死去。我的意思是，我怎么可能不知道呢？
I feel like, as a mom, how could I not know? This little boy thought he was going to die every day, every minute of every day. I mean, how could I have not known that?
我的意思是，就像科迪一直生活在这个不是真实世界的世界里。但你也生活在一个不是真实世界的世界里，因为这一切正在发生，而你却不知道。
I mean, it's like Cody's been living in this world that is not the real world. But you were also living in this world that was not the real world because this was going on, and you didn't know it.
对。对。专家、精神病学家等等，他们会告诉你，你必须原谅自己。我想我就是做不到。我想我的重心仍然在科迪身上。
Right. Right. The specialists and the psychiatrists and all, they'll tell you that you have to forgive yourself. I guess I just don't. I think my focus is just still on Cody.
我向一些关于邪教和洗脑的专家咨询过。当我告诉他们这个故事时，他们的反应就像医生看到有人带着他们认为的一组不寻常症状出现，但医生其实已经见过一百次一样。
I talked to some experts about cults and brainwashing. And when I told them this story, they reacted the way doctors do when someone comes in with what they think is an unusual set of symptoms but that the doctor's seen a hundred times.
没有邪教的官方定义。但他们都说：“是的，听起来像是一个。”邪教往往承诺了解整个世界的关键。追随者被迫保守所有秘密。整个事情逐渐建立，以至于很难在不承认自己一直错误的情况下退出。
There's no official definition of a cult. But they all said, yeah, that sounds like one. Cults often promise the key to understanding the whole world. Followers are pressured to keep everything secret. The whole thing gets built up gradually, so it becomes hard to back out without admitting you were wrong the whole time.
这一切的顶端是一个有魅力的领袖。我问邪教领袖是否知道他们是邪教领袖。答案是，有时知道。这些专家告诉我，没有精神疾病史的完全健康的人也会掉进邪教里。
At the top of it all is a charismatic leader. I asked if cult leaders knew they were cult leaders. The answer, sometimes. These experts told me perfectly healthy people with no history of mental illness fall into cults.
整个事情能运作的部分原因是领袖引入了一些值得恐惧的东西，同时提供解决恐惧的方案，这创造了一种非常紧密的联系。这种技巧当然在很多地方都被使用——广告、政治竞选。在这里只是调到了最大程度。
Part of what makes the whole thing work is that the leader introduces something to be afraid of, while also providing the solution to that fear, which creates this really strong bond. That technique, of course, is used in lots of places-- advertising, political campaigns. Here it's just all turned up to 10.
科迪的爸爸告诉我，这段经历让他理解了新闻中关于父母有一天醒来发现其中一个孩子消失并去加入ISIS的故事。专家告诉我这个案例中感觉不寻常的一点是，这似乎是他们所说的“一对一邪教”——一个领袖，一个追随者。这些可能特别难化解。在非常真实的意义上，就像有人在科迪的大脑里植入了芯片。
Cody's dad told me that this experience helped him understand those stories in the news about parents who wake up one day to discover one of their kids has disappeared and gone off to join ISIS. The one thing the experts told me felt unusual about this case to them is that it seemed to be what they called a one-on-one cult-- one leader, one follower. Those can be particularly hard to undo. In a very real way, it was as if someone had implanted a chip in Cody's brain.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。接下来，科迪的父母试图把芯片从科迪的大脑里取出来，正如你所料，这非常困难。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
David Kestenbaum. Coming up, Cody's parents try to get the chip out of Cody's brain, which, as you might expect, is really hard. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《我大脑里的芯片》。在今天节目的上半部分，如果你刚调到这个频道，我们听到了科迪·特雷比格是如何从他的篮球教练那里得到各种科幻宗教信仰的。在节目的下半部分，他的父母试图让他不再相信那些东西。再次，这是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Chip in My Brain. In the first half of today's show, if you're just tuning in, we heard how Cody Treybig got all kinds of sci-fi religious beliefs from his basketball coach. In this half of the show, his parents try to get him to unbelieve that stuff. Again, here's David Kestenbaum.
科迪说在最初的治疗中，实际上在第一年的大部分时间里，他有一部分是超级愤怒的。比如，“为什么我非要去看心理医生？我没问题。问题在于你们。”
Cody says in the initial therapy sessions, actually for most of the first year, part of him was super angry. Like, why do I have to go to a therapist? There's nothing wrong with me. The problem is with you.
他会有这些小脾气。他的妈妈德鲁会看着他躲在房间里几个小时，她只能等着。有时她会说：“求求你，求求你，跟我说说。”但科迪会爆发。“为什么我不能跟AJ在一起？我们不能都跟他坐下来解决这个问题吗？”
He'd have these tantrums. His mom, Drew, would watch him hole up in his room for hours, and she'd just have to wait. Sometimes she'd say, please, please, talk to me. But Cody would just explode. Why can't I be with AJ? Can't we all just sit down with him and work this out?
情况没有好转，反而出现了这些他陷入那个世界有多深的提醒。比如有一天完全让德鲁措手不及。他们正准备去一个很久以前就计划好的特别家庭旅行。
Instead of getting better, there were just these reminders of how deep in this world he was. Like this one day took Drew totally by surprise. They were preparing to go on a special family trip they had planned ages ago.
他们要去伦敦参加奥运会，记得吗，那正是AJ说可能标志着末日降临、被提可能发生的活动，这意味着光照派将试图给每个人植入RFID芯片。德鲁当时对此一无所知。但他们准备出发的那个早上，科迪就是不肯下床。
They were going to go to London for the Olympics which, remember, was the very event AJ had said might mark the end of days, when the rapture could happen, which meant the Illuminati were going to be trying to implant everybody with RFID chips. Drew didn't know any of that at the time. But the morning they were getting ready to go, Cody would not get out of bed.
所以我——我躺在他身边。我搂住他。我说：“科迪，我们真的需要去机场了。”
So I got-- I laid down next to him. And I put my arms around him. And I said, Cody, we really need to leave for the airport.
我说：“快把衣服穿上吧。你的行李都打包好了。我们走吧。”他用最虚弱的声音告诉我他不能去，就像他已经放弃了一样。他说：“妈妈，我不能，因为我要被杀掉了。”
I said, let's just throw some clothes on you. Your suitcase is packed. Let's just go. And he told me he couldn't in just the weakest voice, almost like he'd given up. He said, Mom, I can't because I'm going to get killed.
德鲁和她丈夫吉米告诉我，他们都觉得，好吧，这是一个我们可以展示给他看，向他证明这一切都不是真实的时刻。只要去奥运会就好了。你会看到的。
Drew and her husband Jimmy told me they both felt like, OK, here is a moment where we can show him, prove to him, that none of this is real. Just come to the Olympics. You'll see.
但他不肯去。他做不到。
But he wouldn't go. He couldn't do it.
科迪认为如果我们去那里就会死掉，这事实很难理解。所以我的意思是，无论逻辑是什么，在精神上，我们怎么谈论都不重要。所以事后，你会进行关于许多不同事情的谈话，你无法真正理解。
The fact that Cody thought we were going to die if we went there, that was a hard thing to understand. So I mean, no matter what the logic was, mentally, there was something that it didn't matter how we talked. So afterwards, you would have conversations like that about many different things that you couldn't really understand.
你如何让某人相信他们的整个世界观是错的？科迪心理医生的看法是你做不到。科迪将不得不自己决定。也许如果你能消除恐惧和焦虑，它会使他的精神免疫系统（如果找不到更好的词的话）发挥作用。科迪将开始自己审视比利时有超级计算机和光照派的想法，并自己想通这一切。
How do you convince someone that their whole worldview is wrong? Cody's therapist's take was that you couldn't. Cody was going to have to decide for himself. Maybe if you could take away the fear and the anxiety, it would allow his mental immune system, for lack of a better word, to function. Cody would start to examine the idea of a supercomputer in Belgium and the Illuminati and think it all through for himself.
那时，很多事情都在科迪身上引发了一种恐怖。如果他被什么东西绊倒或错失罚球，嗯，AJ告诉过他那是魔鬼就在附近的迹象。心理医生给了科迪一些在感到恐慌时让自己冷静下来的方法——呼吸练习，专注于简单的事实。“我在爱我的人身边。”
Back then, lots of things were triggering a kind of terror in Cody. If he'd trip on something or miss foul shots, well, AJ had told him that was a sign the devil was close by. The therapist gave Cody ways to calm himself down when he felt that panic coming-- breathing exercises, simple facts to focus on. I'm around people who love me.
一位处理过此类案件的咨询师以一种真正触动我的方式表达了这一点。他说，你必须帮助苍蝇找到出路离开瓶子，理念是瓶子里的苍蝇不知道它在瓶子里，因为墙壁是透明的。但如果你能让它看到瓶子，它就能找到出路。瓶子里的苍蝇是维特根斯坦写的东西的参考，他是在谈论哲学家。但无论如何，我觉得它很有用。
One counselor who has handled cases like this put it in this way that really stuck with me. He said, you have to help the fly find its way out of the bottle, the idea being that a fly in a bottle doesn't know it's in a bottle because the walls are transparent. But if you can get it to see the bottle, it can find its way out. The fly in a bottle is a reference to something Wittgenstein wrote, and he was talking about philosophers. But whatever, I found it useful.
科迪的心理医生从未告诉科迪他相信的是错的。他只是提问，尝试创造一个科迪感到安全的地方，谈论这些事情并思考它们。科迪确实开始质疑事物。
Cody's therapist never told Cody that what he believed was wrong. He just asked questions, tried to create a place where Cody felt safe to talk about these things and to think about them. Cody did start to question things.
他没有去阅读关于RFID芯片和光照派的内容，而是开始在网上阅读无神论者和宗教学者之间的辩论。他开始喜爱理查德·道金斯（Richard Dawkins）和克里斯托弗·希钦斯（Christopher Hitchens）。但不相信某事很难。
Instead of reading about RFID chips and the Illuminati, Cody started reading debates between atheists and religious scholars online. He grew to love Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens. But unbelieving something is hard.
你不想放弃那个你参与其中的特殊事物。对我来说，回到正常生活并认识到这一切仅此而已——这只是生活，你创造自己的意义——意识到并没有我参与其中的那个特殊事物，这一点真的很难。那只是编出来的。
You don't want to give up that special thing that you're a part of. It was really hard for me to get back to normalcy in life and recognizing that this is all there is to it-- it's just life, and you make your own meaning-- to get to the point where I realized that there wasn't this special thing that I was a part of. It was just made up.
随着时间推移，似乎奏效了。科迪开始有了一些感觉平静的时刻，那些正常的小岛，他不会有疯狂的想法。科迪记得有次治疗后开车回家的情景。
Over time, it seemed to be working. Cody started having these moments where he would feel at peace, little islands of normalcy where he wouldn't have crazy thoughts. Cody remembers driving home after this one therapy session.
在那次车程里，我很开心。我很开心。我只希望它永远持续下去。我想也许会。当然，一旦你开始想，“哦，我很开心”，然后“我希望它不会消失”。然后你就开始吓唬自己。然后一切就结束了。
For that one car ride, I was happy. I was happy. And I just wanted it to last forever. And I thought maybe it would. And of course, once you start to think, oh, I'm happy, and then I hope it doesn't go away. And then you start to scare yourself. And then it's over.
科迪说他的高二那年，仍然深陷AJ描述的那个世界。高三和高四，他可能是一半进去，一半出来。比如如果你问他是否相信光照派，他会说不。但就像他内心深处仍然相信一样。他不断地有强烈的恐慌和焦虑发作。
Cody says his sophomore year, he was still deep in the world that AJ had described. Junior and senior year, he was probably half in, half out. Like if you asked him if he believed in the Illuminati, he would say no. But it was like some deep part of him still did. He kept having these intense episodes of panic and anxiety.
科迪的一个朋友告诉我，科迪不会谈论他受到多么深的影响，以及这些东西仍然伴随着他。但他们能看出他过得很艰难。一个朋友说：“我们试着帮他。但我们懂什么？我们才18岁。”
One of Cody's friends told me that Cody wouldn't talk about how deeply he'd been affected and how this stuff was still with him. But they could tell he was having a hard time. We tried to help him, one said. But what did we know? We were 18 years old.
科迪不得不从高中休学。然后他回去了，完成了学业。他申请了大学，被录取了。科迪想，如果我能做到这一点，如果我能去大学并度过那个阶段，那就像是一份理智证明，一个我会好起来的标志。
Cody had to take a medical leave from high school. Then he went back, finished. He applied to college, got in. And Cody thought, if I can do this, if I can go to college and get through that, it'll be like a certificate of sanity, a sign that I'm going to be OK.
离家只有两个小时。他妈妈告诉他，随时打电话。我能跳上车，两小时内就会赶到。事情看起来顺利了一段时间。但她知道他在挣扎。然后她接到了电话。
It was just two hours from home. His mom told him, call anytime. I can get in a car, and I'll be there in just two hours. Things seemed to be going OK for a while. But she knew he was struggling. And then she got a call.
“我做不到了，”他说，“我做不到了。”她开车去接他，去了他的宿舍，那时她看到了他是怎么生活的。科迪曾向她提到他垫高了床，她以为他把它改造成了阁楼之类的地方来腾出更多空间。但那不是。他把它垫高了一点点，并睡在下面那个小空间里。
I can't do it anymore, he said. I can't do it. She drove to get him, went to his dorm room, which is when she saw how he'd been living. Cody had mentioned to her that he had raised his bed, which she thought meant that he'd converted it into a loft or something to make more space. But that wasn't it. He'd raised it a tiny bit and was sleeping under it in this little space.
当我走进那儿，看到我儿子已经这样睡了几个月又几个月又几个月——那儿可能只有几英寸——我的意思是，我甚至不知道他是怎么滑进去的。从地面到床底的空间太小了。
When I walked in there, and I saw how my son had been sleeping for months and months and months-- there were maybe inches from-- I mean I don't even know how he could have slid under there. The space was so small from the ground to the bottom of the bed.
我意识到那是一个藏身之处。他不是在睡觉。他在藏身。我的意思是，那是他的——我的意思是，他实际上是在藏身。那就是他生活的地方。
And I realized that was a hiding spot. He wasn't sleeping. He was hiding. Like that was his version of a-- I mean, he was literally hiding. And that's where he was living.
我记得当我看到那个时想——我的意思是，我说：“科迪，这就是你一直睡的地方？”他说：“是啊，妈妈。”我不希望他看到我难过，所以我走出了他的房间。我崩溃了，因为我想，我们要——他撑不过去了。我们会失去他。我不是说比喻意义上。我们会真地失去这个孩子。我们会失去他。
And I remember thinking when I saw that-- I mean, I said, Cody, this is where you've been sleeping? And he said, yeah, Mom. And I didn't want him to see me get upset, so I walked out of his room. And I broke down because I thought, we're going to-- he's not going to make it. We're going to lose him. And I don't mean figuratively. We are going to literally lose this kid. We are going to lose him.
科迪后来曾说他考虑过自杀。这似乎是让这一切停止的唯一方法。科迪和妈妈一起开车回家。到此时已经是四年了——四年的，正如科迪所说，尝试修理他自己的大脑。
Cody later said he had thought about killing himself. It seemed like it might be the only way to make this stop. Cody and his mom drove home together. It had been four years at this point-- four years of, as Cody puts it, trying to fix his own brain.
在科迪搬回家后不久，他的父母告诉他有些事他们需要跟他谈谈。他们相当确定这是个坏主意。但他们觉得他们必须告诉他，因为如果他想做，他需要尽快决定。
Sometime after Cody moves home, his parents tell him there's something they need to talk to him about. They're pretty sure it's a bad idea. But they feel like they have to tell him, because if he wants to do it, he needs to decide soon.
这涉及法院，不是篮球场。他们告诉科迪如果他愿意，他可以尝试起诉AJ。这很难。法律没有很好的方式来处理这类案件。
It involved the court, and not a basketball one. They told Cody if he wanted to, he could try to sue AJ. It was a long shot. The law doesn't have a good way to deal with cases like this.
毕竟，没人被绑架。没钱被偷。科迪说没发生过任何身体接触。他们所做的只是谈话。事实上，是谈论宗教，这在我国是受到明确保护的。它写在宪法里。
After all, no one was kidnapped. No money was stolen. Cody says nothing physical ever happened. All they'd done was talk. and in fact, talk about religion, which is specifically protected in this country. It's in the Constitution.
科迪的父母做了一些调查。最好的途径似乎是起诉“蓄意造成精神痛苦”。他们必须证明的法律描述是令人生畏的。这种行为必须是——引用——“性质极其恶劣，程度极其极端，超出了所有体面的界限，在文明社会中被视为残暴且完全不可容忍的。”
Cody's parents had done some research. And the best route seemed to be to sue for intentional infliction of emotional distress. The legal description of what they would have to show was daunting. The conduct had to be, quote, "So outrageous in character and so extreme in degree as to go beyond all possible bounds of decency, and to be regarded as atrocious and utterly intolerable in a civilized community."
如果科迪选择这么做，整个事情可能需要几年。科迪将不得不与AJ待在法庭里。他将不得不公开详细地重温整个事情，同时对方律师会试图阻挠他。最终，他可能会输。或者换句话说，AJ可能会赢。而思考的时间不多了。
If Cody chose to do it, the whole thing could take years. Cody would have to be in a courtroom with AJ. He would have to relive the whole thing in detail in public, while an opposing attorney tried to derail him. In the end, he might lose. Or put another way, AJ might win. And there wasn't much time to think about it.
科迪的生日就在几周内。诉讼时效就要到了。所以他需要在生日前的两到两周半内决定。
Cody's birthday was coming in just a couple of weeks. And the statute of limitations was going to run out. So he would need to decide within the next two, two and a half weeks before his birthday.
科迪考虑了一下。在他生日前一天，他提交了起诉的文件。经过了一年多的法律纠缠。但去年九月，它进入了审判阶段。我当时在场，全程参与了开始部分。
Cody thought about it. And one day before his birthday, he filed the paperwork to go ahead. There was over a year of legal wrangling. But this past September, it went to trial. I was there for the beginning of it.
科迪在审判前有很多担忧。如果他编造了这一切怎么办？他说那其实出现在他脑海里。或者如果当他把这一切告诉陪审团时，他们认为他自己有什么问题，而不是AJ怎么办？
Cody had all kinds of worries leading up to it. What if he had made all this up? He said that actually crossed his mind. Or what if, when he told all this to the jury, they thought there was something wrong with him instead of AJ?
科迪在审判前的几天里有恐慌发作。就像他倒退了。但他站在了陪审团面前。
Cody had panic attacks in the days before the trial. It was like he'd slid backward. But he took the stand in front of the jury.
第一天，我记得非常清楚。我们在健身房里。然后——
The first day, I can remember so vividly. We were in my weight room. And--
科迪的律师说这是一个——引用——“对一个小男孩的秘密操纵和隔离”案件。他称发生的事情是心理折磨。我看陪审团，但他们无法被读懂。他们坐在那儿完全面无表情。科迪在证人席上待了超过七个小时。但他的部分结束了。
Cody's lawyer said this was a case of, quote, "The secret manipulation and isolation of a young boy." He called what happened psychological torture. I looked at the jury, but they were impossible to read. They sat there totally expressionless. Cody was on the stand for over seven hours. But then his part was done.
先生，请为了记录报出你的名字。
Would you state your name for the record, sir?
亚瑟·劳伦斯二世（Arthur Lawrence, Jr.）。
Arthur Lawrence, Jr.
你叫AJ吗？
And do you go by AJ?
是的。
Yes.
这是AJ终于出现了。他衣着整洁，带着一本圣经，是的，个子很高，几乎挤不进证人席。
And here, finally, is AJ. He was neatly dressed, carrying a Bible, and yes, tall, barely fit in the witness stand.
我的下背部太难受了。它在收紧，我对此表示歉意。
My lower back is killing me. It's tightening up, and I apologize for that.
如果你需要更多空间，我们可以移走那两本笔记本。那个小桌子可以折叠起来，如果有帮助的话。
If you need more space, we can move those two notebooks. And that little table will fold down, if that's helpful.
嗯，我指的是这整个木质东西。
Well, I meant this entire wooden thing.
OK，OK，我不能移走所有那些。
OK, OK, I can't remove all of that.
（笑声）
[LAUGHTER]
先生，你多高？
How tall are you, sir?
6英尺6英寸。
6' 6".
好的。劳伦斯先生，你曾经被判过重罪吗？
OK. Mr. Lawrence, have you ever been convicted of a felony?
没有。
No.
你曾经被判过轻罪吗？
Have you ever been convicted of a misdemeanor?
没有。
No.
那是AJ的律师。他问AJ是怎么长大的。
That's AJ's attorney there. He asked AJ how he'd grown up.
我有很棒的父母。妈妈和爸爸用老式的方法抚养我，尊重长辈。是的，先生。不，先生。是的，女士。不，女士。私立、预备、基督教教育，相当酷的生活。
I had great parents. Mom and Dad raised me the old-fashioned way, respect elders. Yes, sir. No, sir. Yes, ma'am. No, ma'am. Private, preparatory, Christian education, a pretty cool life.
OK。
OK.
AJ上过一阵子大学。他说他尝试过NBA发展联盟，但没成功。所以他成了体育教练，经常教孩子。他说家庭很喜欢他。他们对他的工作很满意，包括科迪的家人。
AJ went to college for a bit. He said he'd tried out for the NBA's developmental league but didn't make it. So he became an athletic trainer, often teaching kids. He said families loved him. They were really happy with his work, including Cody's family.
进行得太棒了。我对他能这么快学到东西并理解，感到有些震惊，特别是他的词汇量，哇。
It went fantastic. I was a little bit shocked of Cody's ability to get things quickly and understand them, especially his vocabulary, wow.
你开始教他的时候，他的篮球水平如何？
How were his basketball skills when you started with him?
他会运球。我想我第一次见到他时，我对他做的第一次评估，它是——他运球就像——他能连续运球最多也就三次。他很不擅长。
He could dribble. I think when I first saw him, the first assessment I did with him, it was-- he dribbled like-- the most he was able to dribble consecutively was like three dribbles. He was not good.
当然，他的律师问到了他的宗教信仰。
And, of course, his lawyer asked about his religious beliefs.
你什么时候第一次了解到被提和大灾难？
When did you first learn about the rapture and the tribulation?
抱歉，我刚才情绪化了。我只是记得沃德小姐（Miss Ward）。我真的很爱那位老师。她在六年级的中央集会上向我介绍了这个。
Sorry, I got emotional there. I just remember Miss Ward. I really loved that teacher. She introduced me to that in central assembly in the sixth grade.
大约在AJ开始跟他谈论宗教时科迪的年纪。在审判前我心中的大问题之一是，AJ是否真的相信他告诉科迪的那些宗教内容。一种可能性是AJ会说：“是的，我们谈论过被提，光照派，RFID芯片。所有那些东西都是真的。我在试图拯救他。”
About the same age Cody was when AJ started talking to him about religion. One of the big questions I had going into the trial was whether AJ had actually believed all the religious stuff he'd told Cody. One possibility was that AJ would just say, yes, we talked about the rapture, the Illuminati, RFID chips. All that stuff is real. I was trying to save him.
科迪指出，如果AJ真的相信这一切，为什么他不在法庭上作证？但这并非AJ所说。科迪的律师问AJ关于光照派的事。AJ说，是的，他跟科迪讨论过光照派，但不是作为统治世界的秘密社团。
Cody pointed out that if AJ really did believe it all, why wouldn't he just testify to that in court? But that is not what AJ said. Cody's lawyer asked AJ about the Illuminati. AJ said, yes, he had discussed the Illuminati with Cody, but not as a secret society that ran the world.
我讨论它的背景是我确实相信有一些兄弟会、姐妹会会聚在一起并互相协助。而这可能就是他在互联网上看到的、被称为光照派的社团。
I discussed it in a context that I do believe that there are fraternities, sororities that will cling together and assist others. And that possibly could be a society that he sees on the internet, known as the Illuminati.
当然，在他的Skype信息中，AJ说的是完全不同的东西。他确实似乎相信光照派。他写道——引用——“如果你不听话，光照派会杀掉你。给系统制造麻烦，你就死或者带着他们的印记生活。”
Of course, in his Skype messages, AJ said something very different. He really seemed to believe in the Illuminati. He wrote, quote, "The Illuminati will kill you if you don't do as you're told. Give the system problems, and you die or live with their mark."
科迪的律师也问到了RFID芯片。在Skype上，AJ曾告诉科迪芯片会导致你失去思想控制——引用——“你必须知道这个芯片做了什么！！！”——三个感叹号。
Cody's lawyer also asked about RFID chips. Over Skype, AJ had told Cody the chips cause you to lose mind control, quote, "It's imperative that you know what this chip does!!!" - three exclamation points.
但在证人席上，AJ淡化了这一点，没有说芯片是兽的印记。他谈论它们时就像它们只是他在网上读到的某种新技术。
But on the stand, AJ downplayed that, didn't say the chips were the mark of the beast. He talked about them like they were just some new technology he'd read about online.
我在网上找到了一个链接。我相信它是北卡罗来纳大学做的。而且，还有来自加拿大阿尔伯塔的另一个链接，我相信，上面说有生物特征技术。它来了。它会储存你的信息，等等，等等，还有你所有的东西。
I had found a link online. I believe it was done out of the University of North Carolina. And also, there was another link out of Alberta, Canada, I believe, that said there's biometric technology. It's here. It'll store your information, et cetera, et cetera, and all your stuff.
如果这被一个14岁男孩解读为与此不同的东西，你会感到惊讶吗？
Would you be surprised if this was interpreted as something different than that by a 14-year-old boy?
在这一切之后，（轻笑）我现在并不感到惊讶。
After all this, [CHUCKLES] I'm not surprised now.
顺便问一下，从你笑的样子来看，你认为科迪在那个容易受影响的年纪非常严肃地对待这件事，这很有趣？
I take it, by the way you're laughing about this, that you think it's funny that this was taken very seriously by Cody at the impressionable age you were communicating with him?
不。什么——我确实非常严肃地对待这件事。我的意思是，这是一个法庭。我的意思是，辩护律师，之前我确实没怎么想过这件事，这个Skype或其他什么，它能升级到这个程度，因为这个——
No. What-- I do take this very seriously. I mean, this is a court of law. What I'm implying, Counsel, is before, I didn't really think nothing of this, this Skype or anything, that it can escalate to this level because this--
科迪说他们谈论宗教谈了几年，AJ说他们的对话是最小限度的，加起来一共也就几小时。他说当他们谈论宗教时，是因为科迪要求的。
Where Cody said they had talked about religion for years, AJ said their conversations had been minimal, a matter of hours total. He said when they did talk about religion, it was because Cody had asked.
关于你与科迪进行的那次诉讼主题的沟通，你觉得你有任何道歉吗？
Do you feel like you owe any apologies for the communications you had with Cody about the subject of this lawsuit?
让我们直接跳到一切的结尾吧。我思考过这个问题。我正在看这一切，陪审团和这里的每个人，辩护律师。我真希望我能倒转时间，带特雷比格先生和太太，还有科迪去教堂多一点，这样他们就能看到，他们就能理解这个世界上还有很多其他人。有很多其他基督徒分享我对圣经的相同观点和意见。这样他们就不会把我分类或贴上我是个卑鄙或邪恶的人的标签。
Let's go ahead and just jump to the end of everything. I pondered on this. And I'm looking at all of this and the jury and everybody here, Counsel. And I really wish I could turn back the hands of time and taken Mr. And Mrs. Treybig, Cody to church a lot more so that they can see and they can understand that there are a lot of others in this world. There are a lot of other Christians that share my same views and opinions about the Bible. So then they wouldn't classify me or label me as being a mean or evil person.
这一切都发生在奥斯汀的一个旧法庭里。它的狭小让我震惊。听众席上基本上没有人。很少有证人走上证人席——科迪、他的父母、他的心理医生和AJ。主要的实物证据是那些Skype聊天记录，长达25页。
This all took place in an old courtroom in Austin. I was struck by the smallness of it. There was basically no one in the audience. Very few witnesses took the stand-- Cody, his parents, his therapist, and AJ. The main piece of physical evidence was those Skype transcripts, 25 pages long.
这就是我们想出来的解决人与人之间纠纷的系统。我们把一堆陌生人聚在一起，陪审团，他们只需要决定他们认为发生了什么以及它有多糟糕。科迪的律师在结案陈词中说，他们没有要求具体数额的赔偿金。但他表示科迪的心理医生费用总计超过76,000美元。而陪审团可以加上他们认为适当的精神损失赔偿。
This is the system we've come up with for settling disputes between people. We get a bunch of strangers together, the jury, who just have to decide what they think happened and how bad it was. Cody's lawyer, in his closing statement, said they weren't asking for a specific amount of money in damages. But he said Cody's therapist fees had totaled over $76,000. And the jury could add whatever they thought was appropriate for mental anguish.
AJ的代理律师在结案陈词中说，没人能确定为什么科迪会受到如此强烈的影响。成千上万或数百万美国人分享AJ的宗教信仰，他说。为什么我们没有精神病院里塞满了害怕被提的孩子？
AJ's attorney, in his closing statement, said no one could know for sure why Cody was so strongly affected. Thousands or millions of Americans share AJ's religious beliefs, he said. Why don't we have mental hospitals filled with kids who are terrified of the rapture?
陪审团仍然完全面无表情，周五休庭进行评议。发生的事情是否超出了所有可能的体面界限？它在文明社区中是否残暴且完全不可容忍？那天晚上，我收到了科迪的这条语音留言。
The jury, still totally expressionless, recessed on Friday to deliberate. Was what happened beyond all possible bounds of decency? Was it atrocious and utterly intolerable in a civilized community? That evening, I got this voicemail from Cody.
嘿，大卫。我是科迪。而（叹气），哇，我们赢了。陪审团达成一致意见。我太开心了。我想唱歌。我想大喊。我想跳舞。
Hey, David. This is Cody. And [SIGHS] wow, we won. The jury came back unanimous. And I'm just so happy. I want to sing. I want to shout. I want to dance.
我只是——太久以来，他是我生命中无法触及的虚构人物。（沉重地叹气）这太神奇了。我这辈子从来没这么开心过。这就是我能说的全部。
I'm just-- for so long, he was this mythical figure in my life that I couldn't touch. [SIGHS HEAVILY] It's amazing. And I'm the happiest I've ever been in my life. And that's all I can say.
有一件事科迪在那条消息中没有提到——判决金额。陪审团只判给科迪4美元的赔偿，基本上是最低限度——1美元医疗，1美元精神损失，等等，这看起来很奇怪。他们同意AJ确实做了超出所有体面界限的事。但当谈到给那个数字标价时，他们的答案是4美元。
There is one thing Cody did not mention in that message-- the amount of the judgment. The jury awarded Cody just $4 in damages, basically the minimum-- $1 for medical care, $1 for mental anguish, et cetera, which seemed weird. They agreed that AJ had done this thing that was beyond all possible bounds of decency. But when it came time to put a dollar figure on that, their answer was $4.
审判后我们跟五名陪审员谈过。所以我可以告诉你发生了什么。被选出来领导讨论、而且在现实生活中正好是一位法官的陪审长告诉我，他们以一次快速投票开始，看看每个人站在什么立场。
We talked to five members of the jury after the trial. So I can tell you what happened. The presiding juror who they picked to lead the discussion, and who happens to be a judge in real life, told me they started with a quick vote to see where everyone stood.
七名陪审员投了赞成票，准备让AJ承担责任。三名不确定，两名反对。所以他们辩论并阅读了Skype聊天记录。然后他们进行了另一次投票，10票赞成，两票不确定，都是男性。
Seven jurors were yeses, ready to hold AJ liable. Three were undecided, and two were nos. So they debated and read through the Skype transcripts. And they took another vote, 10 yeses, two undecideds, both of them men.
陪审长告诉我两件事似乎赢得了最后两票。一个是陪审团里的母亲们，她们直接行动起来。另一个是只判4美元赔偿的想法。每个人都喜欢那个主意。
The presiding juror told me two things seemed to win over the last two. One was the mothers on the jury, who just kind of went to town. And the other was this idea of awarding just $4 in damages. And everyone liked that idea.
对一些人来说，这是一种承认也许AJ没意识到他正在造成的伤害的方式。在法律上，他们只需要确定他的行为是鲁莽的，不一定是故意的。一些陪审员似乎认为AJ确实相信关于RFID芯片和所有那些东西。
For some, it was a way to acknowledge that maybe AJ hadn't known the harm he was causing. Legally, they only had to determine that his behavior had been reckless, not necessarily intentional. It seemed to some of the jurors that AJ actually believed the stuff about RFID chips and all that.
但对许多陪审员来说，4美元是一种帮助科迪将此事抛在脑后的方式。科迪的家庭不需要钱。他们想，如果他们选一个大额数字，是的，那会惩罚AJ。但他可能没能力支付，那只会让整件事拖延，更多的法律纠纷。也许AJ会上诉。所有人不得不再次经历这一切。
But for a lot of the jurors, the $4 was a way to help Cody put this behind him. Cody's family didn't need any money. And they figured, if they picked a large dollar amount, yes, that would punish AJ. But he probably wouldn't be able to pay it, which would just drag this whole thing out, more legal stuff. Maybe AJ would appeal. And everyone would have to go through this whole thing again.
所以4美元。我不确定那是陪审团该有的想法，但他们确实这么做了。审判后，一些陪审员拥抱了科迪或走过来谈话。一个人告诉我他也试着找AJ说祝好运。但他已经离开了。
So $4. I'm not sure that's how the jury was supposed to think about things, but it's what they did. After the trial, some of the jurors hugged Cody or came over to talk. One told me he also tried to find AJ to say good luck. But he'd already left.
我通常认为法院是决定谁进监狱，或某人欠某人多少钱的地方。在这里，它做着更基础的事情，只是说谁对了，决定记录下实际发生了什么。正如我所说，审判后，AJ终于同意跟我们谈谈了。
I usually think of courts as deciding who goes to prison or how much money someone owes someone else. Here, it was doing something much more basic, just saying who was right, deciding for the record what actually happened. As I said, after the trial, AJ did finally agree to talk to us.
嘿，大卫。
Hey, David.
这是AJ吗？
Is this AJ?
是我。
This is he.
我最感兴趣的是，这一切到底是关于什么的？他为什么要对科迪说那些话？但在我们的谈话中，AJ基本上否认说过那些话。他说科迪编造了这一切或夸大了。
The thing I was most interested in was, what was it all about? Why did he say all that stuff to Cody? But in our conversation, AJ basically denied saying those things. He said Cody made it all up or exaggerated.
他告诉我他坚持他在法庭上说的一切，100%。而且他正计划上诉这一裁决。所以我换了一种方法。忘记他是否对科迪说了那些话。他相信那些东西吗？在法庭上不知怎么的，没人问过他那个简单的问题。
He told me he stood by everything he said in court, 100%. And he's planning to appeal the ruling. So I took a different approach. Forget about what he said or didn't say to Cody. Did he believe those things? Somehow in court, no one had asked him that simple question.
那我可以问你关于RFID芯片吗？在法庭上，似乎你是在说你把RFID芯片看作只是某种用于储存你数据的新技术，而且你给科迪发过某条新闻报道的链接。
So can I ask you about RFID chips? In court, it seemed like you were saying you viewed RFID chips as just some new piece of technology to store data about you and that you'd sent Cody a link to some news story.
但随后在Skype记录中，科迪写道：“它们对你的身体做了什么？”你写道：“你失去了思想控制。”而且，你还跟他进行了关于如果他父母强迫他植入RFID芯片该怎么办的完整讨论。所以到底是哪个？你认为RFID芯片只是小电脑芯片，还是你认为它们是光照派想植入每个人体内的兽的印记，你相信吗？
But then in the Skype transcripts, Cody writes, "What do they do to your body?" And you write, "You lose mind control." And also, you have this whole discussion with him about what to do if his parents make him get an RFID chip implanted. So which is it? Do you think RFID chips are just little computer chips or you think they're the mark of the beast that the Illuminati want to implant in everyone?
你对射频有多了解？如果你在广播业工作，你应该知道很多。（轻笑）对吧？（笑着）
How familiar are you with radio frequency? If you're in broadcasting, you should know quite a bit. [CHUCKLES] Right? [LAUGHING]
告诉我一些关于射频的事。告诉我一些在此时有用的关于射频的事。
Tell me something about radio frequencies. Tell me something that's useful here about radio frequencies.
嗯，关于它的是你在采访我。我没在采访你。我没在这里教你关于射频的事。
Well, the thing about it is you're interviewing me. I'm not interviewing you. I'm not here to educate you about radio frequency.
不，我只是在问个问题。你似乎是在说有什么重要的事情我应该知道，关于射频的，那会帮助我理解这一切，所以——
No, I'm just asking a question. You seemed to say that there's something important I should know about radio frequencies that would help me understand this, so--
好吧，让我们从它们是什么开始。射频识别，就是它，OK？你口袋里可能有信用卡。它里面有个芯片。
Well, let's start off with what they are. Radio frequency identification is what it is, OK? You have a credit card probably in your pocket. And it has a chip in it.
是的。所以这就是你认为的全部吗？你认为它也是兽的印记吗？而且是光照派想植入每个人体内并控制你思想的东西，你相信吗？
Yeah. So is that all you think it is? Do you think it's the mark of the beast also? And that it's something the Illuminati want to implant in everybody and will control your mind, do you believe that?
嗯，首先，在法庭上，那是——我会反对那点。它叫复合提问，OK？
Well, first of all, in a court of law, that's-- I would object to that. It's called compounding, OK?
嗯，你——
Well, do you--
所以如果你要问我一个问题——
So if you're going to ask me a question--
OK。
OK.
——我的意思是，问我一个具体的。别把话塞进我嘴里，别诱导我。
--I mean, ask me a specific one. Don't put words in my mouth and don't lead me.
OK。你相信——
OK. Do you believe--
我真希望你别那样做。
I really wish you wouldn't do that.
你相信RFID芯片是，或者可能是，兽的印记吗？
Do you believe RFID chips are, or could be, the mark of the beast?
我相信它可能是一个兽的印记的潜在前传，基于它所说的，它所陈述的，在经文中。
I believe that it could be a potential prequel to the mark of the beast based upon what it says, what it states, in scripture.
我告诉AJ专家们告诉我的，这看起来像是一个一对一邪教。他说他不是任何邪教的一部分。
I told AJ what the experts told me, that this seemed like a one-on-one cult. He said he's not part of any cult.
你现在怎么看科迪？
How do you feel about Cody now?
阐述一下。
Elaborate.
我不知道。我的意思是，你在生他的气吗？
I don't know. I mean, are you angry at him?
我为他感到难过。我为他感到难过。我真的是。我很失望。我很悲伤。但你知道吗？生活是关于选择的。所以在审判日，他将不得不站在父亲面前。而那是——复仇是属于父亲的。
I feel sorry for him. I feel sorry for him. I really do. I'm really disappointed. I'm sad. But you know what? Life is about choices. So on Judgment Day, he'll have to stand before the father. And that's-- vengeance is that of the father.
如果你问我听了四天的证词，阅读审判文件，采访家庭和其他孩子，以及AJ两个小时后，我对这一切有什么看法，我认为AJ相信所有他告诉科迪的东西。我找到了一个在这一切之前就认识AJ的人，他说他一直充满热情地谈论RFID芯片和光照派。
If you ask me what I make of all this after listening to four days of testimony, reading through the trial documents, interviewing the family and other kids and AJ for two hours, I think AJ believes all the stuff he told Cody. I found someone who knew AJ before all this, who said he talked about RFID chips and the Illuminati all the time, with enthusiasm.
我认为AJ的诉求和科迪的一样。这是一个他身处中心的故事。我认为他学会了如何以一种吸引人们进入的方式展示它。而科迪是一个崇拜AJ的甜美孩子。
I think the appeal for AJ is the same as it was for Cody. It's a story he is at the center of. I think he's learned how to present it in a way that draws people in. And Cody was a sweet kid who adored AJ.
审判后我去拜访了科迪。看起来审判案件确实把他这件事的最后一部分抛在了身后。就像科迪克服了他对被提和光照派的恐惧。但他仍然有一个更普通的恐惧。他害怕一个人。但在法庭上，AJ看起来并不超自然。他看起来非常像个人。
I went to visit Cody after the trial. It did seem like the court case had put some final piece of this thing behind him. It was like Cody had gotten over his fear of the rapture and the Illuminati. But he still had a much more ordinary fear. He was afraid of a person. But in court, AJ did not seem supernatural. He seemed very human.
你看着他，你说，你只是个男人。你只是个人。
You look at him, and you say, you're just a guy. You're just a person.
这件事之所以对你如此有影响力，是不是因为你活在那个关于世界是如何运作的完全不同的版本里太久了。而在此时，你终于决定了什么是真实的。现在你把它展示给了一群别人，在我们要决定什么是真实、发生了什么的设定中。他们说了“是的”。
Is part of why this was so powerful for you that you lived for so long with this totally other version of how the world was. And here's the time where you've finally decided what is real. And now you've shown it to a bunch of other people in this very setting where we are supposed to decide what is real and what happened. And they said yes.
正是如此。你回头看，你简直无法相信你说出的那些事真的发生了。对我来说，那现在是疯狂的事。那是疯狂的事。而它发生在你身上，这很奇怪。
That's exactly it. You look back, and you just can't believe that the things you're saying actually happened. It's crazy stuff to me now. It's crazy stuff. And that it happened to you, it's weird.
我认为那是苍蝇最终从外面看着瓶子时说的话。
I think those are the words of a fly finally looking at the bottle from the outside.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，他是我们节目的制作人之一。
David Kestenbaum, he's one of the producers of our show.
（音乐——Living Color的《Cult of Personality》）
[MUSIC - "CULT OF PERSONALITY" BY LIVING COLOR]
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）制作。我们的员工包括本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、BA·帕克（BA Parker）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的管理编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming. Our staff includes Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Kimberly Henderson, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
（致谢）
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
今天是我们的制作研究员BA·帕克在职的最后一天。她从电影教授的工作来到这里。她离开时是一位广播制作人和散文家。我们都期待着很快在广播节目中听到她的故事。
Today is the last day for our production fellow BA Parker. She came here from her job as a film professor. She leaves a radio producer and essayist. We all look forward to having her stories here on the radio show very soon.
特别公告，我们全新、重新设计的网站是thisamericanlife.org，有许多新功能。我们还有一个全新的应用程序。我们的应用程序在iPhone和Android上都可用。我们的员工惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和塞思·林德（Seth Lind）让这一切成为可能。
A special announcement, our brand new, newly-designed website is at thisamericanlife.org, with lots of new features. We also have a brand new app. Our app is available for both iPhone and Android. Whitney Dangerfield, Julie Whitaker, and Seth Lind on our staff made all that happen.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心传递给公共广播电台。和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托尼·马拉蒂亚（Tony Malatia）先生。你知道，他每次看到花园侏儒时总是那么难过。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Tony Malatia. You know, he always gets so sad when he sees a garden gnome.
他们有眼却不能看。他们有耳却不能听。
They have eyes, but they can't see. They have ears, but they can't hear.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是伊拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，欢迎收听更多《美国生活》的故事。